I’ve been making videos for a lot of years,
and whether it's for Vox or The New York Times
or for the channel, music is easily one of the
biggest things that changes how a video feels.
Music like this... If you've been around for
a while, you've definitely heard me say things
like this before... That thing that inspires me is
music. So I started working with this guy. That’s
a good sound. This is Tom. Tom Fox. We've been
collaborating since 2018 and now five years later,
Tom is the full time composer here in the
studio. He makes the music for every one of the
videos. Why does a small independent journalism
production studio on YouTube need a full time
composer? That’s absurd! Yes, it is absurd and
it's completely necessary. And it is what makes
these videos shine. From the Europe videos to the
Putin videos, to the videos about Doritos. Every
one of these has a different tone and feel because
we crafted music that fits for that story. Well,
there's now a place where you can listen to
this music. It is called The Listening Room,
it's totally free up on YouTube right
now. You can listen to it while you work,
while you study, while you work out...
See you in The Listening Room, everyone!